What you've been writing and thinking
about and people's reaction to it
intersects with tonight's debate.
Uh,
because you've been quite vocal on
the topic of political correctness.
No fan of the radical left and it,
you know,
and people might say,
well,
does that mean you support the radical,
right?
It's like,
just because you're no fan of the
radical left doesn't mean you support the
radical,
right?
That's an absolutely a
preposterous proposition.
But the universities,
especially the humanities
and social sciences,
are absolutely dominated
by left wing thinking.
That's well documented by
people like Jonathan Heit.
It's not my imagination.
And I find the doctrine that unites
them to be unconscionably pernicious.
It's basically a collectivist doctrine.
And the thing that disturbs me about it,
but there's every reason
to have a left wing.
The reason you need a left wing is
partly because being left wing is in part
temperamental.
It's not going away.
And also because when our
society produces hierarchies,
which will inevitably do,
people tend to stack up at
the bottom of hierarchies.
It's in the nature of hierarchies
to produce that as an outcome.
And what that means is that the people
who are dispossessed in the hierarchical
arrangements need a voice and
that's the left obviously,
and and fair enough.
But it's also obvious that just
as the right can go too far,
the left can go too far,
but when the left goes too far is
something that's very ill defined.
And to me that's,
that's not acceptable given that we
know that the left can go too far and I
think they've certainly gone too far in
the universities and the postmodern neo
Marxists pastiche that
makes up the radical left
philosophy that's at the bottom
of the social sciences and humanities
now is there's nothing about it that's
useful as far as I'm concerned,
that has nothing to do with compassion,
has nothing to do with lack of my lack of,
what would you say?
Empathy.
Yeah,
precisely.
They're completely separate issues.
And that's another thing that really
bothers me about political correctness.
It's like,
well,
we have a hammer lock on empathy.
It's like a empathy is not enough.
It's not even close to enough.
And an excess of empathy
can do terrible things.
And B,
no,
you don't have a hammerlock on empathy.
And to ally that with a philosophy that
essentially assigns people to their
identity via their group membership.
And then to read not only
the current state of affairs,
but history itself as a battleground
between competing groups is,
I think it's dangerous.
I think it's obvious that it's dangerous
if you know anything about history,
but one you're sure to hear tonight
is this idea of privilege
that certain people by virtue,
uh,
Uni,
by virtue of our,
our race,
our class,
our gender,
have enjoyed historically privilege in
society and it's time that that privilege
be shared more equitably across groups
who've been historically disadvantaged.
Well,
that's a good example of the
conflation of empathy with ideology.
It's like first of all,
the majority in any society has privilege.
That's the whole point of the society is
to set up a system so that the bulk of
the people in the system
can do well while,
and then you have you built
in protection for minorities.
So to conflate that with
race is not acceptable.
It's a kind of,
it's a toxic sleight of hand and
it's extraordinarily dangerous.
So apart from that,
it's an empty claim.
Some people have advantages
that other people don't.
Well obviously,
and if you take apart anyone into the
multitude of categories that they can be
taken apart into,
what you'll find is that on
some of those dimensions,
they're doing better than other people
for rather arbitrary reasons sometimes.
And on other dimensions
they're doing worse.
So it purple.
And then the next part of that
is while historically speaking,
it's like,
okay,
over what span of time do you mean?
Precisely so you mean because my
ancestors 150 years ago were privileged
comparatively speaking,
that I should somehow pay for that now.
And Are you so sure.
My ancestors were so privileged
as far as I can tell.
My grandparents on my father's side,
my father grew up in a log
cabin until he was five.
He had like three rooms.
My grandmother was a cleaning woman,
fur fur farms in the,
in this,
in central Saskatchewan in the 1930s
she cooked for threshing cruise.
You know,
she chopped wood piles that were as big
as the damn cabin to get through the
winter.
It's like where?
Where's the privilege?
I see it accrues to me as
a consequence of my race.
Oh,
I see.
So we're now we're going to have
a discussion about race are Wayne.
That's,
and that's the thing about the toxic
left is that everything is about group
identity.
And so let's say,
let's even take the argument
further though and say,
okay,
well because of my skin color,
I'm differentially privileged.
Okay.
So from,
from a historical perspective,
so,
so what you're going to make everybody
be on the basis of their race now pay for
some historical inequity and
you're going to view the,
the history of the relationships between
men and women as one fundamentally of
oppression.
That's the way we're going to play this
is that it wasn't that men and women see
fundamentally cooperated throughout
history to bring themselves out of the
fundamental catastrophe that
history has always been.
That isn't what it was.
Despite the fact that in 1895 the typical
person in the western world lived on
less than a dollar a day.
By today's standards,
which is far below the UN's current
guidelines for abject poverty.
We're going to revisit that.
We're going to say no.
Really,
the fundamental reality of the world
was that men are oppressed women.
It's like,
yeah.
So that brings me to a second argument
that you are no doubt going to hear
tonight,
which is that,
you know,
men need to check their privilege.
That there's an idea here that,
uh,
you know,
women in particular the me too movement.
There's been a,
an awareness and awakening the part of
the power of women in society and it's
time that,
that be acknowledged.
What will be your response to that?
Well,
first of all,
when the discussion is about power,
you know,
that sends a shutter up
my spine immediately,
partly because part of
the postmodern doctrine,
especially in its
alliance with neo Marxism,
which is squirrel,
strangest alliance by,
by my estimates,
everything's about power.
And I don't believe that.
I think that hierarchies are only about
power when they've already transformed
themselves into tyrannies.
And I don't think that the fundamental
hierarchies that characterize the west
art t radical comparatively speaking,
like compared to the heavenly
hierarchy in your utopian imagination,
no doubt there exemplars of pure hell,
but compared to everywhere else in the
world right now and every other hierarchy
throughout history,
we're doing pretty damn well.
And the fact is is that once
we had reliable birth control,
which really only happened in the 1960s,
women were welcomed most fundamentally,
although also opposed,
but most fundamentally welcomed into
every position of authority and competence
that could possibly be laid open to them,
to the point where now they
make up something like it's
damn near three quarters
of humanities and social
sciences students,
they dominate the healthcare fields.
So how fast do you expect the
transformation to take place?
While the argument is,
well,
it would've never happened
without political pressure.
It's like,
yeah,
no,
sorry.
What triggered it was reliable birth
control and that made it possible.
It was reliable,
birth control and reliable,
um,
menstrual sanitation and all of those
things that no one ever takes into account
that made the playing field open
and it's transformed utterly.
And in what,
50 years,
how fast do you think
these things can happen?
Good point.
So,
and I'm certainly not against
equality of opportunity.
You have to be here.
You have,
I dunno what has to be wrong with you
to be against equality of opportunity.
You know,
even if you're selfish,
if you're not absolutely out for
destruction and you're only selfish,
let's say anybody with any sense would
go for equality of opportunity at least
because it gives you the possibility
of exploiting the maximum number of
qualified and talented people.
So,
and equality of outcome.
Well,
we'll save that for the debate tonight.
I'm sure it'll come up.
Final question.
I'm asking all of you pre debate.
Where do you think this debate
is going to go from here?
Do you think we're,
we're in a kind of cultural spasm or
do you think there's something more
fundamental happening in our culture,
a new tribalism,
a new set of antagonisms they're
going to take much longer to work at?
I think it'll depend on how well we each
behave in the next 10 years because I
think things could get way
better everywhere really fast,
or we could degenerate back
into our idiot 20th century.
Tribalisms and I would say,
if I had to bet,
well,
you know,
it's,
what are you seeing?
You're out there,
you're in the public's.
Uh,
I,
I really,
I would say that
there's plenty of pressure
in both directions.
You know,
I'm heartened by the
fact that so many people
have been taking the
psychological material that
I've been providing online to
heart and doing what they can
to put themselves together.
I'm disheartened by the fact that
everything now is transformed into,
well,
virtually everything is transformed
into a polarized political argument.
And there seems to be no understanding
of the fact that not everything is
actually political.
I actually don't think that,
I don't think the discussion
about political correctness,
political,
I think it's,
I think it's both theological
and philosophical,
but it's,
it's always presented are often
presented in politicize terms,
not least because if you're influenced
by the radical leftist collective
collectivist ideology,
that is the only playing field.
It's all hierarchies at each
other's throats playing power games.
It's it.
The free speech thing is
really interesting because
on the radical left end of
things,
this,
there is no debate about free speech.
You can't have a debate about free speech
from that ideological position because
there isn't any such thing.
All there is is those who are maneuvering
for power within their respective
groups making claims that benefit from,
yeah.
That's the basic axiom of
the interpretive system,
so free speech.
It isn't that it isn't.
The reason that free speech has
become politicized is because
if you adopt the collectivist viewpoint,
it's a shibboleth.
It's a fantasy.
You might think you're speaking freely,
but you're not.
You're just expanding on that.
How prevalent gender absolutely.
Smile.
My Rez.
Anyway,
part,
one of the things that's funny about
the postmodern insistence on identity,
I think it's absolutely comical in a very,
very dark,
is the emergence of intersectionality
because the intersectional theorists
actually identified the Achilles
heel of the collectivist perspective.
You know,
because what they pointed out was,
well,
let's say we cover the standard groups.
I don't know why these
are the standard groups,
but let's say sex,
ethnicity and race for
the sake of argument.
Well,
what about how they interact?
It's like,
yeah,
what about that?
What about the fact that gender
is infinitely differentiable,
not least from the left wing perspective.
And what about the fact that
there's endless numbers of
ethnic variance and what
are you going to do?
You're going to control for the
interaction between all of those.
And the answer is yes.
That's what we'll try to do
before we give up our radiology.
But the fact of the matter is,
is that the reason the
west decided on a radical,
individualistic perspective to begin
with is because we figured out 2000 years
ago,
at least at the origins of
this type of thinking that,
okay,
everyone is so unique that you can frack,
you can fraction hate their group
identity right down to the level of the
individual.
[inaudible] well,
so,
yeah.
Yeah.
I don't know what's going to happen.
I think the universities for example,
I think they've done themselves yet.
I don't think they can escape from,
cause I,
I,
I've watched large organizations crumble
and that can happen very often and
okay.
One serious error.
We'll do it.
And I think I've tried to lay it out.
I think the universities have
made seven serious errors.
You don't want,
we're gonna have to say those for the
stage tonight and then universities will
absolutely be a topic of our discussion.
Okay.
But a real pleasure to get a taste for
your remarks and appreciate your passion
and your,
uh,
a willingness to,
to step onto the stage and engage with
other people's ideas in a spirit of free
and open exchange.
Yeah.
Hopefully it will go well and it'll be
an intelligent discussion and we'll get
somewhere.